[Music]
what distinguishes greatness what
distinguishes those who succeed from
those who fail is not alone their
expertise it is this parallel set of
skills about how do you deal with
challenge how do you approach a problem
how do you adapt a skillset to a new
environment or a new context how do you
communicate in trying and difficult
circumstances in ways that doesn't cause
everyone around you to scatter like the
wind that is what distinguishes the
truly successful from those who are you
know who only accomplish you know at a
median level or consider themselves
failures a big thing significance
relevance and actionability are our
editorial guide stars they are the the
principles that we consider in every
case when we say is this worth our time
is this worth our attention or is it not
and thinking through them and the
relationships between each and the
trade-offs that exist between them you
know easy defines the work that we do
there are still far too few outlets who
think like this you know almost none
relative to the need for these and
instead what we've seen is a
proliferation of sort of news derivative
content might be funny news and might be
listicles it might be news slanted to
the right or to the left
it is now fake news news that is made up
either deliberately or through some sort
of daisy chain of miscommunication but
none of them come at the problem by
saying what is the best way to invest
your next 60 seconds or three minutes or
10 minutes so that we can leave you as
maximally enriched as possible no one
does that
except for big think so edge is the
inevitable
evolution of our mission of getting
helping people get smarter faster if big
think is a Metsa plate a sort of sampler
platter of so many different types of
things all informed and inspired by this
idea that we need to be focusing on
what's significant relevant and
actionable edge is the next level we
asked ourselves a couple of questions
one was what is the most valuable
learning that can be delivered through
the tools that we have at hand the tools
that we have at hand or video the
internet great thinkers and doers
watching somebody of great distinction
face-to-face what is it that they could
tell you that would be most useful there
is a set of ideas and a set of skills we
call them soft skills that are really
the habits of mind and the and the
practices of discipline that are the
connective tissue between the formal
hard skills that they possess and those
are the things that we really wanted to
drill into I've often compared it to
sitting down for dinner with a great
hero or a role model the most valuable
thing you could learn from from from a
luminary
or somebody you admire so much really
should be framed around you around
what is transferable here what is it
that you have done that I can do to and
what is not constrained by the gaps in
our respective expertise but rather is
really more a function of your life
experience and observations and how you
managed and amplified that formal skill
set in the context of applying it in the
world and that's really what edge has
emerged as a body of totally
transferable soft skills
captured from the world's greatest
thinkers but really framed from the
vantage point of view the user you the
viewer and the outcome I believe is
we've created the most valuable single
library of such content of a mentorship
rich insight driven applied learning
that has ever been created
[Music]